cher françois chers amis nous avons le
plaisir cet après-midi d'accueillir jean
michel blanquer vous le voyez pas encore
à l'écran il va apparaître dans quelques
instants je le vois sur les retours il a
le même temps que nous avons à guidel
cette année c'est à dire un grand soleil
et ça nous fait très plaisir de
l'accueillir une nouvelle fois puisque
jean michel blanquer est sans doute l'un
des membres du gouvernement qui a ses
habitudes à guidel où il a été très
régulièrement invités la politique de
l'éducation c'est une priorité pour le
modem et nous avons avec françois avec
le mouvement démocrate avec sarah el
hajri avec nathalie et limaces eu
l'occasion à de nombreuses reprises
d'aborder cette question avec toi lors
de tes participation à guidel et notre
remercions d'être une nouvelle fois
présent parmi nous même si c'est à
distance je vous remercie d'accueillir
jean michel blanquer
merci beaucoup jean-noël merci
merci pour cet accueil et c'est vrai je
crois que je suis venu physiquement ou
virtuellement chaque année et vous me
permettrez d'ailleurs pour commencer
d'avoir une pensée pour marielle puisque
la dernière fois que je suis venu je la
vois encore avec son beau sourire les
accueillons et donc j'ai évidemment une
pensée pour elle comme j'imagine vous
l'avez en permanence pendant toutes ces
journées et merci à toi jean noël pour
l'invitation merci à eux ça m'a
évidement fait très plaisir jeu pour
rien au monde n'aurait raté le fait de
pouvoir vous parler même si j'aurais
aimé encore plus être être présent merci
à françois bien sûr et à vous tous je
veux à ma patrie qui doit être la marque
jacqueline geneviève mes collègues du
gouvernement et puis vous le savez je
suis devenue un fief modem depuis un peu
plus d'un an avec l'arrivée de nathalie
et et de sarah que je salue aussi je
sais qu'elles ont beaucoup participé aux
ateliers et donc je suis toujours très
heureux d'être en convergence avec vous
et en rencontres avec vous merci pour
pour cette invitation je sais que vous
avez déjà abordé des thèmes très
important et qui sont essentielles non
seulement pour le prochain programme
présidentiel et législatif mais tout
simplement pour pour la france vous avez
parlé d'écologie humaniste de
démocraties d'europe bien sur l'égalité
des chances autant de sujets d'ailleurs
que
je touche moi même je pense d'ailleurs
aux thèmes européens dont on vient de
parler clément boon qui est si essentiel
et auquel nous participons tous si hier
j'étais justement dans ces conférences
qu'il organise pour ma part c'était à
strasbourg et c'est l'occasion de
pousser le terme le thème européen dans
sa dimension les dans ses dimensions les
plus concrètes et je signale au passage
que d'ailleurs l'éducation devient de
plus en plus un sujet européen je le
pousse comme tel et nous allons faire
avancer beaucoup de sujets à l'occasion
de la présidence française de l'union
européenne comme par exemple la
circulation des professeurs en europe la
formation des professeurs conçu de
manière plus européenne et la mobilité
des lycéens professionnels donc des
sujets très concrets et très européen à
la fois donc vous avez abordé beaucoup
de sujets je voudrais dans le temps qui
m'est imparti essayer d'être
complémentaire de ce que de ce qui a pu
se dire et puis peut-être lancer le
débat parce que je crois que vous avez
prévu que sauf erreur qui avait des
échanges avec la salle
en
voulant finalement développé une idée
assez simple mais à mes yeux extrêmement
importante c'est qu'au fond on est dans
une période historique très particulière
très complexe où la démocratie peut se
sentir fragilisé et alors même que dans
les années 90 nous pensions que
l'horizon démocratique et est ouvert ces
dernières années nous pouvons avoir le
sentiment d'une inquiétude démocratique
aussi bien d'un point de vue externe
puisque sur le plan géopolitique des
régimes autoritaires gagnent du terrain
mais aussi sur le plan interne puisqu'il
y à des forces anti démocratiques
antirépublicaine qui prennent de
l'importance dans notre pays comme dans
d'autres pays et on doit évidemment
s'inquiéter des facteurs de cela les
analyser et évidemment avoir une
contre-offensive
démocratiques fortes et l'idée assez
simple mais qui nous emmène dans
beaucoup d'endroits que je voudrais tout
simplement défendre c'est que ce qui
sauvera la démocratie c'est la
république dans dans les années
précédentes dans les décennies
précédentes
on a parfois eu tendance à opposer les
deux mots
peut-être parce qu aux états unis il ya
un parti démocrate est un parti
républicain
mais qui ont des avec un sens très
différent du sens que nous pouvons
donner en france à mes yeux la
démocratie sera
sauvé par la république parce que la
république porte justement ce qui peut
permettre de consolider ce qu'on
considère comme étant les piliers
habituels de la démocratie et qui sont
fragilisés dans la période que nous
vivons parce que finalement c'est quoi
les piliers de la démocratie ça va
m'amener évidemment à parler d'éducation
le premier des piliers c'est le mot
peut-être le plus important en politique
essentiel au moment de la révolution
française et même avant dans la pensée
des lumières et ce mot c'est celui de
liberté la liberté c'est donc dans la
déclaration de 1789 la garantie des
droits les libertés se sont multipliées
depuis deux siècles de siècle à la
faveur de différentes conquêtes mais
aujourd'hui on la voit fragilisé soit
parce que les libertés rencontre
contradiction entre elle-même soit parce
que les libertés sont menacées par
différentes dimensions de notre vie il
est évident que la crise sanitaire est
un grand défi pour la liberté que
certains ont même été jusqu'à dire que
les régimes autoritaires et était plus
efficace dans la lutte contre la crise
sanitaire parce que plus capable de
restreindre la liberté je crois que
c'est une fierté qu'on peut avoir en
france d'avoir eu un président de la
république qui avec sa majorité son
gouvernement a su mettre le curseur de
la restriction des libertés ou à l'
endroit minimales nécessaires pour aller
vers cette crise sanitaire et pouvoir la
gérer et il est évident que quand nous
en sortirons pleinement nous devons
chérir plus que jamais la liberté et
défendre les libère et mettre la liberté
au centre de la pensée politique
c'est une idée profondément
républicaines et c'est ce qui renforce
la démocratie la garantie des droits
c'est le premier principe est si
important aussi que les institutions
préserve cette liberté ce qui amène à la
deuxième idée démocratique fondamental
elle aussi fragilisé parfois dans le
monde contemporain c'est à dire la
séparation des pouvoirs là aussi dès
1789 la séparation des pouvoirs est
essentiel et cette séparation des
pouvoirs elle est parfois malmenée dans
le monde dans lequel dans lequel nous
vivons
le pouvoir exécutif le pouvoir
législatif le pouvoir judiciaire mais
aussi bien d'autres bien d'autres
pouvoirs je pense aux au pouvoir
médiatique qui est devenu essentiel
aujourd'hui et qui parfois manque de
contre-pouvoir c'est tout l'enjeu des
fakes news de la difficulté que l'on a
aujourd'hui à ce que une vérité sereine
et un débat basée sur des éléments
rationnels s'installe dans le débat
public au lieu de différent de tester
les radicalisations diverses et des
irrationalités diverses qui nous avons
de nouveau la pensée républicaine le
pensais me paraît essentiel face à cela
d'abord parce que celle la compagne de
la notion de séparation des pouvoirs
mais aussi parce qu'elle vient justement
avec le thème de l'éducation l'éducation
a été dans l'histoire de la république
l'élément de consolidation fondamentale
tout la troisième république se
consolida en même temps que l'école de
la république se consolide et d'ailleurs
d'une certaine façon on peut faire un
parallélisme entre la fragilisation de
notre démocratie et la fragilisation de
notre éducation lorsqu il y a les
mouvements anti vaccins un peu
importants ces derniers temps on peut
faire un parallèle avec un affaissement
de la culture scientifique dans la
population générale et avec un certain
nombre de d'abaissement de la pensée
logique dans dans notre débat public
c'est pourquoi le thème éducatif est si
essentiel c'est la colonne vertébrale de
notre pays et c'est à mes yeux le
chantier fondamental je vais beaucoup
dit et écrit ces derniers temps et puis
surtout avec vous tous et je vous
remercie de soutien indéfectible que
j'ai toujours eu du modem notamment à
l'assemblée nationale mais aussi avec
vous les militants les élus
c'est pour cela que nous nous sommes
attelés à à cette renaissance finalement
dû système éducatif français depuis
depuis 2010 est alors cette renaissance
elle passe notamment par l'école
primaire vous souvenez de ce que je
disais ici même à l'invitation de
françois en septembre 2010 est sur nos
objectifs qui étaient notamment le leur
la consolidation des savoirs
fondamentaux chez les élèves
je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous commençons
à voir les premiers fruits de cette de
cette politique le dédoublement des
classes est souvent vu comme étant
l'avant garde de cette de cette
politique et nous savons que c'est
essentiel parce que c'est à la fois un
sujet de consolidation des savoirs
fondamentaux mais aussi l'égalité
sociale et rappelons que ça touche 400
mille enfants parents désormais puisque
notre dédoublant aussi une bonne partie
des grandes sections de réseau
d'éducation prioritaire chaque année
dont 400 mille enfants avec un roulement
cent cinquante mille nouveaux chaque
année
bénéficient de cette politique les
premiers enfants qui ont bénéficié de
cette politique entre en cm2 certaine et
ils sont donc c'était 60 milles et 150
mille d'entre eux rentrer en cm1 sa
peine et les premières observations
qu'on a les premières analyses nous
incite à l'optimisme
c'est des élèves qui sont mieux partis
dans leur vie scolaire qui ont de
meilleurs résultats et aujourd'hui où
pour la première fois depuis des
décennies nous nous contrôlons la
fluence en lecture à l'entrée en sixième
nous nous donnons les moyens de vérifier
que tout ceci est en train de se
consolider pendant ces quatre ans nous
avons mis l'essentiel de nos
augmentations budgétaires dans l'école
primaire pour créer des postes alors
même qu'il y a les élèves en moins ce
qui est d'ailleurs un sujet grave et
important je sais bien que françois
s'est saisie au titre de ses fonctions
de commissaire au plan et qui était
évidemment un thème de débat que je vais
pas aborder maintenant métier
fondamental c'est à dire la démographie
mais il trouve qu'on a moins d'enfants
et qu'on a quand même créé des postes à
l'école primaire 7500 potes qui nous
permettent non seulement de faire cette
ce dédoublement
mais aussi différentes politiques en
faveur des directeurs d'école en faveur
de l'école rurale etc etc l'amélioration
de la situation à l'école primaire est
aujourd'hui une donnée forte de la même
façon vous le savez la politique de voir
fait au collège qui est fait pour là
aussi élever le niveau général et lutter
contre les inégalités sociales et puis
en troisième lieu les réformes du lycée
professionnel et du lycée général et
technologique sont faites là aussi pour
élever le niveau général puisque on a
des élèves qui choisissent davantage ce
qu'ils font là c'est les fameuses
enseignement de spécialité au lycée et
là les quelques premiers échos qu'on dab
de certains acteurs de première année de
l'enseignement supérieur je pense aux
classes prépas par exemple nous disent
qu'on a des élèves quand même plus
motivés sachant davantage pour présenter
les choses et pourquoi ils ont choisi
bien sûr sur ce deuxième sujet qui est
celui du lycée les geler les choses elle
aussi prennent du temps et les résultats
se verront dans la durée et puis nous
avons quand même été durement affectés
par la crise sanitaire et d'ailleurs et
certains problèmes de l'année dernière
due à la crise sanitaire peuvent
interférer avec l'évolution de réformes
pour autant nous sommes le pays qui a
maintenu ses écoles ouverts et le pays
qui a continué à creuser un sillon de
réformes à mes yeux fondamental
sans se laisser détourner par la crise
sanitaire nous en verrons les résultats
nous les verrons dans les enquêtes
internationales et prochaines années je
pense à un pisa de l'année prochaine qui
sera publiée l'année suivant
c'est pourquoi j'ai d'ailleurs je mets
en garde contre toute une série
d'articles d'intervention que l'on voit
ça et là où on fait référence par
exemple à pisa 2000 18 pour dire la
france est en déclin et ne
continue son déclin non les enquêtes
internationales ne nous dise strictement
rien des résultats des politiques
éducatives française depuis 2010 est la
dernière grande étude c'est pisa 2018 sa
porte sur des élèves dans 15 ans à ce
moment là et évidemment ça ne dit rien
de ce que de ce qui a pu être fait et
les vraies enquêtes internationales
si traduiront ça sont même pas celle des
prochaines années mais encore celle des
années suivantes néanmoins je pense que
nous que nous mesurerons serbe ont assez
vite et en tout cas nos évaluations
nationales nous permettent d'être
confiants sur ce point j'insiste cela
dans le cadre de ce que je vous disais
sur la république consolidant la
démocratie puisque je pense que c'est
l'école de la république qui peut
consolider la démocratie il n'ya pas de
démocratie si on n'a pas une population
qui de manière aussi homogène que
possible bénéficie d'un bon niveau
d'éducation si on ne lutte pas contre
les inégalités sociales par l'égalité
des chances et ce qui permet une société
de liberté c'est une société qui a une
école solide pour tous donnant notamment
un bon départ dans la vie grâce aux
savoirs fondamentaux et pour cela il
faut un sillon c'est pourquoi je suis
heureux de pouvoir continuer dans ce
ministère encore encore maintenant je
pense que le signal qui est envoyé comme
françois laver avait su le donnait en
son temps c'est un signal de stabilité
c'est-à-dire de capacité à mener une
politique pendant un temps suffisamment
long pour pouvoir imprimer quelque chose
en étant conscient que les sujets
éducatif ne se résolvent pas du jour au
lendemain
ce qu'il faut pour cela de la suite dans
les idées comment alors je suis heureux
pour cette action de compter avec
nathalie et limaces et sarah et la
grille en plus de roxana maracineanu
c'est important de dire aussi que depuis
un peu plus d'un an maintenant depuis
juillet 2020 nous développons une vision
qui elle aussi très fortement dans la
tradition de la république c'est-à-dire
une vision complète de l'enfant en ayant
l'éducation nationale la jeunesse et les
sports dans un même dans un même
ensemble c'est ce qui nous plaisait a
permis par exemple de faire les vacances
apprenantes depuis l'été 2020 c'est ce
qui nous permettent de développer le
plan mercredi et je cite les élus locaux
parmi vous savent de quoi on parle quand
on quand on évoque cela est la dimension
sociale et éducative que tout ceci
comporte donc l'équipe que nous formons
ensemble tous les quatre depuis juillet
2020 et plus largement avec la majorité
parlementaire est avec vous tous qui qui
nous soutenaient nous aider nous relayer
nous inspirer pour cette action bien
cette équipe
travaille pour que justement l'égalité
des chances soit une réalité quand on
développe cette année par exemple le
pass culture et le passeport qui
concrètement permettre une ouverture
vers la culture de tous les enfants de
france et les trafics sportif un maximum
d'enfants en france nous sommes
évidemment dans un travail
socio-éducatif profondément républicain
est profondément consolidant pour la
démocratie
nous sommes environnés de discours
pessimiste gris
catastrophiste de tous ordres avec
souvent des arguments qu'on peut
complètement entendre sur la crise
climatique par exemple les inquiétudes
sur les enjeux migratoires sur les
menaces liées aux technologies
technologies par exemple contrôle social
tel qu'il se développe en chine
actuellement tous les nouvelles
technologies donc c'est vrai qu'il y à
des phénomènes mondiaux nationaux qui
parfois par s assombrir le futur
mais en même temps nous avons la
conviction que en prenant les choses à
bras le corps en ayant une vision non
seulement françaises mais aussi
européennes de la nécessité d'avoir des
politiques publiques adaptées de
défendre nos valeurs sont d'abord et
avant tout des valeurs de liberté et
bien on peut y arriver et moi qui vais
souvent dans les classes je régénère
souvent mon optimisme à cette
fréquentation des classes chaque fois
que je parle de tous ces sujets j'ai en
tête ces enfants que je rencontre ces
professeurs peuvent répondre à ces
différents de l'écho qui est donnée dans
les médias de tout cela et ce que je
vois c'est tout simplement une capacité
à travailler
j'utilise volontairement ce verbe parce
que je crois que l'enjeu de la valeur
travail avec celui de la liberté fait
partie des grands enjeux peut-être même
ceux de la campagne présidentielle parce
que c'est aussi quelque chose qui a pu
être touchés ou abîmés par la cristiani
terre et qui doit être défendu et je
vois donc des enfants et des adultes
pour qui le travail veut dire quelque
chose pour qui le progrès veut dire
quelque chose pour qu'ils optimisent me
veut dire quelque chose et qui sentent
bien que la bonne volonté quand elle est
là et je crois qu'on peut parler de
bonne volonté pour notre action publique
est bien rencontre leur bonne volonté
donc je pense que le mot politique n'a
jamais eu autant d'importance
qu'actuellement et dans cette année pré
électorale il en a beaucoup parce que
les enjeux sont gigantesques cd en
cheveux qui sont à l'échelle de
l'histoire qui sont à l'échelle du monde
et qui sont à l'échelle de notre pays et
ses gens de ces enjeux seront relevés je
terminerai mon propos par cela ils
seront relevés d'abord et avant tout pas
seulement mais d'abord et avant tout par
l'éducation l'éducation est la clé de
tout pour l'avenir ça a toujours été
vrai mais c'est encore plus vrai que
jamais c'est encore plus vrai parce
qu'on sort d'une crise sanitaire
gravissime où la moitié des enfants du
monde ont pu être privés d'école a
beaucoup ou
fortement
de ce point de vue là on peut se réjouir
de ce que nous avons pu faire en france
et on doit avoir conscience que c'est
une catastrophe éducatif qui s'est passé
à l'échelle mondiale qui suppose donc
des investissements éducative à
l'échelle du monde c'est ce que j'ai
plaidé dans dans le livre que j'ai sorti
récemment c'est à dire le fait que nous
ayons une vision renouvelée
à l'échelle française européenne et
mondiale
de l'argent public qui doit être
consacrée à l'éducation pour préparer
des sociétés de paix de fraternité et
des sociétés démocratiques ces pistes là
sont concrètes elles sont réelles elles
sont reliées à nos valeurs
philosophiques de liberté mais elle
suppose d'être vraiment au travail pour
être au travail il faut être unis donc
je ne dois pas aussi les les enjeux
organisations politiques qui sont aussi
présents dans ce congrès de guidel et
bien entendu je m'y intéresser je trouve
que c'est très important qu'on soit bien
organisé pour les échéances qui arrivent
et nous serons d'autant plus unie que
les enjeux d'organisation seront reliés
aux grands enjeux politiques
philosophiques de sociétés qui sont ceux
de notre temps et je sais que le modem
est toujours à la pointe de ces
réflexions c'est pourquoi j'ai plaisir
est avec vous aujourd'hui comme tout le
reste de l'année j'ai plaisir à
travailler avec le modem et le tout avec
l'équipe que je constitue avec les deux
secrétaires d'état modem merci à vous
toutes et à vous tous et je suis
évidemment ouvert à la discussion
[Musique]
bonjour
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le
dispositif des vacances apprenantes qui
a été mis en place comme vous l'avez dit
à partir de 2020 et qui est né dans un
contexte un peu exceptionnel ce
dispositif a eu beaucoup de succès que
ce soit pour l'écolo apprenantes l'été
du pro l'école ouverte où mon patrimoine
à vélo je voulais savoir si vous
comptiez maintenir ce dispositif dans
les années à venir voilà merci beaucoup
c'est une très bonne question je très
heureux d'approfondir un peu ce thème
avec vous
c'est vrai que c'est les vacances à
prenantes sont nés dans le contexte de
crise sanitaire aiguë c'est à dire l'été
2020 lorsque après le premier
confinement notre grand objectif c'était
que les enfants puissent avoir au
maximum des vacances prendre l'air mais
aussi rattrapé autant que possible ce
qu'ils avaient pu perdre du fait du
confinement
mais cette a été une occasion donc de
mettre les bouchées doubles pour
améliorer le droit aux vacances des
enfants et nous savons que c'est un
aussi un très grand enjeu social que
d'arriver à ce que tous les enfants de
france puissent partir en vacances mais
aussi de développer d'une autre qualité
de ce qu'on offre comme vacances aux
enfants depuis plusieurs décennies il y
avait un déclin des fameuses colonie de
vacances qui avaient connu leur apogée
après guerre et jusqu'aux années 70 et
ce déclin on l'attribué souvent au fait
que finalement il y avait peut-être une
perte qualitative y avait été en quelque
sorte démodé est-ce que les vacances à
prenantes ont permis c'est une sorte de
rebond des colonies de vacances et des
formules qu'on propose aux enfants de
tous les milieux sociaux grâce à un
concept rénové et moon et de citer
plusieurs choses puisque c'est les
vacances apprenantes regroupe en effet
plusieurs formules il y en a une que
j'aime beaucoup je vous l'avais site et
à la fin c'est mes vacances à vélo par
exemple c'est quelque chose de tout
simple mais de formidable c'est à dire
dans proposons aux enfants en étant
encadré bien sûr de partir plusieurs
jours à vélo à la découverte de la
nature et du patrimoine environnant
c'est donc apprenant parce que ces
traits culturels d'ailleurs et puis on
apprend plein de choses
tout ceci donc est tellement bien qu'il
fallait le reconduire et on l'a fait
avec je les fais avec le soutien du
premier ministre et donc on a reconduit
les vacances apprenantes en 2021 en
ayant d'ailleurs plus le temps de les
préparer et j'ai évidemment été l'avocat
de leur perpétuation donc elles seront
perpétuer à l'été 2000 22 et ça fera
évidemment partie de notre programme
politique parce que les vacances
apprenantes font partie de cette vision
éducatif en plus on doit avoir pour les
enfants et il faut toujours avoir en
tête que le temps scolaire représente la
minorité du temps de l'enfant dans que
ce soit à l'échelle quotidienne
hebdomadaire ou annuel et que l'on doit
donc s'intéresser à tout ce qui a des
éducatifs dans ce qui lui arrive en
dehors de ce plan scolaire et donc les
vacances apprenantes font partie de ce
qu'on pourrait appeler à c'est un mot un
peu peut-être bizarre mais le legs
positif de la crise sanitaire c'est à
dire que parce que nous avons su tous
collectivement être résilient par
rapport à ce défi posé et bien il y a
certaines façons de faire qui resteront
après la crise et qui seront utiles et
là je pense le rebond des colonies de
vacances notre capacité à régénérer
notre vision du temps extrascolaire de
l'enfant fera partie je l'espère de ce
que nous aurons appris de positif dans
notre façon de voir cette crise
merci une deuxième question très
rapidement parce que le temps file oui
bonjour monsieur ministre ma question
concerne les enfants qui ont des besoins
particuliers nous que les enfants
atypique qui sont atteints de troubles
dys de tdah alors on a eu la chance au
mois de juin d'avoir la première journée
nationale du tdah et je voulais savoir
dans le cadre de l'école
comment comment le gouvernement commet
on pouvait accompagner les familles mais
aussi les enfants pour qu'ils trouvent
leur place dans
l'école publique 1 je vous remercie
merci beaucoup très très grande question
aussi qui rejoint d'ailleurs l'un des
mots clés qu'on doit avoir pour
qualifier l'évolution en cours de notre
système éducatif c'est à dire la
personnalisation des parcours
tous les enfants ont droit à l'école et
chaque enfant est un cas particulier et
l'école doit être capable de
personnaliser le parcours de l'enfant a
fortiori quand cet enfant a un trouble x
ou y
c'est ce qui a été rassemblée sous le
sous là sous la formule services publics
de l'école inclusive c'est à dire de
capacité à accueillir les élèves en
situation de handicap et plus
globalement les élèves ayant des
troubles dys par exemple en font partie
comme vous avez ça a été un petit archi
prioritaire c'est même là dessus que le
président de république s'est prononcé
entre les deux tours quand on lui a
demandé de de dire ce qui était sa
grande priorité
et depuis 2010 est on est passé de 70 me
laver sage qui étaient des contrats
aidés à 125000 cdd et cdi
et tout un travail qualitatif par
exemple pendant le premier confinement
les ressources en ligne que l'on a mis
sur ces sujets tout un travail
qualitatif de formation des intervenants
d'organisation sur le terrain ce qu'on
appelle les piannencs c'est à dire une
capacité à organiser sur plusieurs
établissements notre gestion des enjeux
des enfants handicapés j'ai saisi dès le
début du quinquennat le conseil
scientifique de l'éducation nationale de
ce sud du sujet des 10 et plus
globalement de notre capacité à nous
adapter aux besoins des élèves ayant des
problématiques de 2,7 de cette famille
est compris tdh et donc c'est un sujet
sur lequel nous avançons non seulement
type de l'école inclusive non seulement
au titre aussi de la passation des
examens là mais aussi aux types de la
pédagogie et de la formation des
professeurs parce qu'un des enjeux
majeurs mais vous le savez bien puisque
j'ai l'impression que c'est bien le
sujet c'est la formation initiale et
continue des professeurs sur ces
questions au travers de la loi pour
l'école de la confiance on a
systématisée le fait que cette formation
aux différents handicaps des troubles
dys fasse partie de la formation des
professeurs et donc c'est quelque chose
qui se déploie on n'est
jamais parfait sur ces questions il ya
évidemment encore bien des problèmes
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a créé des
comités départementaux pour que toute
famille qui est difficultés en la
matière puis se joindre un interlocuteur
est exposé le problème et pour regarder
comment on peut résoudre ce problème
mais je crois quand on regarde le chemin
parcouru il est quand même assez assez
important et il y aura encore des
progrès à faire surtout dans un sens
qualitatif parce que je pense que dans
le sens quantitatif on a on a quand même
désormais quatre cent mille enfants
intégrés à l'école et qui auraient
autrefois étaient considérés comme
n'allant pas nécessairement à l'école et
autour de ses enfants tout un travail
qui est fait de formation des
intervenants
merci beaucoup jean michel blanquer
remercier d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous tomberez l'applaudir bientôt
android
mais bon congrès à tous à très bientôt à
bientôt